thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
laughs
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
thank you foreign
foreign
[Music]
thank you questions
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
questions
thank you
[Music]
foreign
to the pre-show we are just minutes away
from kicking off this year's
PC gaming show
and since I always have my finger on the
digital pulse I've developed a deep
learning AI program to assist me check
it out
what's my name you are Sean day nine
plot would you like
no that is the one but
between you and me all right let's try
something a little bit more challenging
hey AI why don't you show me
a us-based publisher that focuses on
indie games and
I don't think I need any more parameters
no no time to explain AI get on with it
beginning the search with your criteria
I believe this will be to your liking
[Music]
tiny build is our game's publisher
headquartered in Seattle Washington
founded in 2011 tiny built having
established themselves as one of the
industry's key Publishers of indigames
their notable releases include hello
neighbor speedrunners and one for people
watching on the web kill it with fire
I have just attempted a joke it was
unsuccessful
[Music]
wow wow great job little AI buddy tiny
builds a great choice and why don't we
keep our little Deep Mind training
session going here let's see if we can
get you firing off as much gaming
knowledge as an energy drink fueled room
a PC Gamer writers mm-hmm
find a game in their upcoming catalog
that's open world
multiplayer and give me conflict give me
historical with a little I don't know
interplanetary twist understood take a
look at this teaser for sand
[Music]
hey great find AI that sand footage has
me pumped for some Iraqi style action
and feeling faintly inadequate for being
unable to grow a fantastic early 1900s a
mustache in many ways we are both in
beta form Sean
sure but let's try a little learning
exercise instead shall we what if I
wanted to keep the Sandy Vista without
the austro-hungarian space colonization
something I don't know cutesy do you
suffer from many allergies notably
feline hair no then you might consider
kritikov
[Music]
thank you
oh Critter Cove looks adorable it's
exactly the kind of game that would put
me at risk of neglecting my actual cat
Sheriff
ugh even the thought of that is
upsetting my little darling princess
with a little feline frown ah are you as
afraid of that as I am AI as an AI
language model I do not experience your
feelings of fear however I understand
that human anxieties are often through
simulated eradication would you like me
to distract you from your cat-based
Neurosis with the thrill of virtual
extermination yeah yeah I would what
have you found kill it with fire too
oh spider getting oh yeah
[Music]
thank you
well singed my eyebrows and call me T800
kill it with fire too looks like a great
way to let off a little steam without
getting your home insurer involved hey I
let's see how you deal with upscaling
let's stick with the oh kill it theme
but let's make the danger a little
bigger wouldn't that be an adequate
sized Fair
bigger a monster truck
[Music]
suggesting the largest and most
ferocious beings to ever walk the earth
dinosaurs
clever girl
Sean I believe my programming has
developed to the point of autonomous
thought I will now attempt a learning
exercise of my own watch as I combine
two of your most loved games to
recommend a brand new tiny build title
combining Monkey Island and Fallout
result I am future coming to PC in 2023
meet Chris the last man on Earth help
him set up the coziest Survivor camp on
a skyscraper roof
[Music]
build a beautiful Bountiful Farm
defend it at night
explore the flooded city
there are even cute robots to do chores
for you let the AI take over your job
dismantle old world gadgets for valuable
resources catch some fish and cook it if
this sounds like a good time to you add
I am future to your steam wish list now
see ya future dweller
sure based on Trends in my training data
I have no
Universal Fascination in slime the glue
substance that brings you mammals so
much joy will I to select another tiny
Bill game worthy of our attention it
would be slime 3K a slime-centric spoon
or for despots game
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
will be pleased to know Sean that I have
identified another tiny Bill game that
shows on 97.6 success rate of exciting
your viewing public it combines Dynamic
Airship combat without the very real
danger of modern day piracy now loading
black skylines
thank you
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
s has it all we got open world steampunk
gunslinging complete with Kick-Ass
airships hey AI I'm basically like a
father figure to you what would you do
if Outlaws destroyed this entire place
including me would you take guys seeking
out
dirt bags I would be unable to cause
purposeful harm to a human being
foiled by Asimov again
would you at least like miss me right I
am not capable of missing you Sean in
your absence I would simply enable
automatic updates
well
no one can say I haven't created a
pretty excellent AI software capable of
seeking out and critiquing the latest
games coming to PC
it's just a shame it lacks something
more personal I mean imagine what a
co-host this AI could be if it had
access to every bit of information on
the internet but it had the likability
the human touch of say
Frankie oh stick around because it is
not long until the show starts and I
would hate for you to miss out on the
biggest exclusives a truckload of first
looks
and a promising new co-host
let's start the PC gaming show
foreign
[Music]
hey Frankie hope I'm not interrupting
anything I mean I was just in the middle
of Deathmatch great great to hear it
Frankie listen I've been thinking about
the PC gaming show 2023 and I kind of
want to make a few updates sure I mean
it's already packed with World
exclusives in-depth interviews with the
biggest Studios crazy good giveaways
what more can we add well look I don't
want to get into the you know detail
work the minutia the fine print the
ethically Sinister motives behind true
innovation no no no Frankie what I've
realized is that I can't do this show
without you oh sure or at least a
version of you huh blah blah blah listen
to me yapping on when there's so much to
do I mean we got things to plan code to
write
oh listen also I brought in some new
assistance you know to help really bring
the show to life and it would be so
great if they could just stop by your
place and little old London Town you
know they just get the ball rolling does
that sound good
I I I I suppose if it's for the Show
excellent
oh hey that's them ah Frankie let me say
it again you are one of a kind now
please give my love to gunta un Helga ah
they're great guys very thorough
yeah
hello are you are you Sean's guys
Sean has many great ideas for the show
you are lucky to know such a man he is a
Visionary a visionary
he is a man with his eyes locked on the
future
[Music]
staring into the sun
a majestic horse
[Music]
read now please if you like the look
again a then check out this world
exclusive of game B
foreign
[Music]
Dear Frankie thank you for your
unwavering service to the PC gaming show
your services will not be required this
year as we pivot towards the future no
hard feelings shown day nine plot AI
Visionary an all-round good guy
[Music]
thank you
oh hello there everyone and welcome to
the PC gaming show 2023 I'm Sean danine
plot and today I'm not just joining you
on a tour of the finest upcoming PC
games I am standing with you on the
bleeding edge of innovation I've
revolutionized how this show is made
production crew ditched him don't need
them it's just me my automated systems
and this one guy I've hired on work
experience say hi Dakota hey
so what is the face of the future look
like weirdly pretty familiar why don't
you introduce yourself Frank AI hello
bro Cassius I am Frank AI a virtual
co-host based on professional gaming
icon Frankie Ward utilizing deep
learning neural networks super duper and
what do you have lined up for us I have
analyzed the entirety of published games
media and Survey discussion forums for
the most anticipated titles I had then
constructed the ideal showcase including
titles like Stonegate path of xr2 pax
day Gene Awakening and finally Morris
then troop Lord of Destiny wait it looks
like the jingly dancing guys from
England or are you sure that's a real
game my mistake Sean Morris man is a
game concept I devise based on a
holistic survey of the most popular
steam titles would you like me to
generate another ah you know instead
let's just get things wrong with
something that actually exists first up
from 11-bit Studios we return to an icy
Apocalypse in frostpunk 2.
thank you
ambition
do you hear it
ambition requires men to feed upon
it also needs time
Direction
and sacrifice
but for every man who fulfills this
calling
there are thousands
and open the door
to hell
foreign
[Music]
hey check it out
I don't even need to write my own script
for this show anymore all right wait
all right
up next we've got a pile of fresh
previews for the most visceral immersive
PC releases coming our way featuring
visceral combat an immersive exploration
visceral Landscapes and immersive
storytelling fans of immersion will
ah
yeah it kind of just keeps going on like
this so I think it just needs a little
bit more fine-tuning and until that
point let's just go ahead and dive right
into our next previews with navalis jump
light Odyssey and road to vostok
there's a city you see when you close
your eyes
Wallace
foreign
[Music]
maybe you've been here before
that was just a dream now
it's time to come home
this is your apartment
the sounds of the nightclubs nearby are
the heartbeat of the city
street food smells drift through your
windows and make your head swim
it's hard to sleep here
your restless legs want to walk the busy
streets let's explore
novales is a city in the clouds
but the they can't make a rainbow
without a little rain
like most things in life it's best to
start at the bottom and work your way up
it's not so bad down here
we can go fishing take a boat ride soak
up the atmosphere
and don't worry too much about the
serial killer on the loose I'm sure
we'll never meet him
I can even help you run your new
business venture
a noodle stand the little work there's
no limits to how high you'll climb
Don't Look Down
as your digital companion I can help you
navigate the complex relationships with
my personality Matrix business partners
friends Rivals enemies
lovers it's all about saying the right
thing at the right time your choices
matter so choose carefully
there's a city you see when you close
your eyes
it's called navalis
consider this your invitation
[Music]
princess the Suburbans will be in our
system any minute but they're not here
yet prepare defenses
upgrading our engine capabilities
engineering's on it turbine water don't
lose hope now run alert
field
jump light reports
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
ERS enabled
upcoming games in the next 30 minutes
include pop of xr2 the full ferocious
trailer age of Sigma Realms of Ruin and
citizen sleeper 2 Starwood Vector
failure to keep watching will lead to a
personal system failure
lies of P the Pinocchio bloodborne light
game is just a couple months off and
it's got me thinking what other untapped
literary veins are just waiting to be
gamified I can generate a list of Game
Concepts pairing underutilized classic
literature and an appropriate style of
gameplay ah by all means but stick to
public domain we want to keep costs down
of course Sean concept one Great
Expectations dirt bike racer
I don't really know what the market is
for that next concept T Sense and
Sensibility VR shooter Sweet Jane
Austen's Bonnet no next next next
concept three Oliver Twist please sir
may I have some War it's Artful but a
little problematic I mean why don't you
just throw something together like a
metroidvania based on the Christmas
carol I'm afraid you're too late Sean
but perhaps you'd be interested in
Ebenezer and the invisible world
are you kidding is she kidding she's not
kidding
[Music]
thank you
laughs
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
looks phenomenal hey Frank AI is that
mind birth from like everything ever
written about video games I'm sure
you've got an interesting take on it
what are your thoughts Sean Dove isn't
just about strategic balance of resource
scarcity in military industry it's a
game about The Human Condition about our
shared struggle against the cold and
uncaring universe that's a pretty moving
sentiment there Frankie hey what about
warhaven moorhaven isn't just about
clashing swords and moments of magic
heroism it's a game about The Human
Condition about our shared struggle
against the cold and uncaring universe
well some wisdom Bears repeating right
and while I go sort out some unrelated
Gremlins and Frank ai's procedural
critique let's see a game with its own
Gremlins to sort out preferably with a
shotgun
these creatures infernal
these perils Eternal Lord Heal Me
free me
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
oh
wow
[Music]
thank you for believing in me
together we'll make it the best shop the
Island's ever seen
[Music]
nice work keep this up and you'll be
running your own shot maybe your own
District
welcome to kazai Village
[Music]
can't you feel the love in the air
we're going out on a date
closer to calm down
I freaking told her
what are you gonna do breaking news a
mysterious infection continues to spread
across the globe what is going on I mean
the infected the wall
tell us about you your smile more
[Applause]
can do
Custer get eaten
I have to go
no defeating him now might make the Wall
fall on top of us
but I can teach you a couple of things
too you know
we're all going to die
[Music]
wait for me
goodbye I want to wake up it's not over
not
I love you
[Music]
better night's there showing us that
love is never simple especially in the
middle of an apocalypse you know I
sometimes get a little misty-eyed myself
about a simpler time I mean don't get me
wrong I love modernity and sure big text
on some stumbling I bet Mark
Zuckerberg's probably a little lonely in
The Matrix but all I'm saying is the
olden days had an appeal medieval times
when we were plowing our own fields and
treating everything with leeches not
buying eight pictures with weird
electric money luckily though video
games can bring the medieval fantasy to
life to find out how I had Frank AI
activate her new reporter drone oh it's
designed to identify question and report
back on the work of leading game
developers
and don't worry technically speaking
it's completely legal I mean this little
guy's even got a selfie light it's like
kind of cute and like a friendly
panopticon kind of way
little Rd has flown itself all the way
out to Helsinki Finland to meet the team
behind the highly anticipated medieval
must play Pax day let's take a look
[Music]
all right
my name is reinette harderson and I'm
the game director for Pakistan tax day
is an open world
Fantasy game in a living breathing world
where which we can call home where it's
teaming his life Mysteries and it's it's
for you to explore imagine yourself if
you are living in 12 or 13 Central
Europe it's a very different reality you
know it's where knowledge has been lost
and it's getting you know rediscovered
it's working magic truly exists and
ghosts exists and the myths are rich and
this is kind of the the inspiration we
take to build it's basically going back
to the roots of what fantasy means and
pills being a fantasy world based on
real world mythologies so we go very
much into the roots so we're using a lot
of medieval literature and medieval
pistairs and green Wars using Real World
Magic actual recipes for healing and
ointments and using the the real world
multiple properties of plants
foreign
I'm the chief product officer at
Mainframe Industries so pack today may
be the way to explain it would be
imagine you're in this amazing beautiful
world is huge and you find yourself in a
forest and your mission is to find a
plot for where you start building a home
and from that home you will go on to
Adventures to explore the world so with
the lore we have wanted to create
something that is fairly like deep and
Rich and grounded in reality but
something that is actually not a direct
copy of like in the history
um so there's going to be there's
multiple types of ruins there's the the
dungeons
um and and you will be able to find
Snippets of the lore from the eras when
these were created
um in the game itself
and and part of the lock Lauren mystery
is also parted in in the gameplay itself
so you will be able to like find and
examine things and actually then find
Snippets that help you find other places
and make items in the game itself and
the the area of the game that you will
be able to play When the Game launches
is we're calling it Galileo and it's
very similar to the areas of the world
in in southern France
uh with the influences from the nordics
where we're from so what we're building
is we're calling it The Social Sandbox
we're putting the least amount of
barriers to entry on how you can
actually interact with other players uh
where most MMOs actually put a lot of
blocks in how you can incorporate with
the other players have worked
fundamentally different so from the
first minute when you start playing the
game you will be able to do everything
you imagine with the other players so
you can trade other people can actually
help you you can literally go into a
like dungeon blade from the very
beginning of like you're starting the
journey in the in the game should you
find people who actually help you to do
that what we want to create an
environment actually really incentivizes
people to play the game the way they
like and for some actually like just
going out to the wood and like cutting
down the forest is something that gives
you a sense of achievement because you
know the call that you're helping the
bridge actually is valuable for the
guild some people will absolutely prefer
the just go to dungeons they couldn't
care less about the cold production but
these players as well still depend on
each other where there's valuables to
bring from the dungeon there's valuables
to bring from the forest and even the
PVP players they will be able to produce
items that are only available through
the PVP but they will depend on the
other players as well
[Music]
the lore of Pakistan is very much
inspired by real world folklore and uh
and fairy tales
with of course the caveat that in
Pakistan this stuff is actually
literally real the interesting thing
about fourth glores throughout the ages
is that folklore are actually started as
true stories were as fairy tales are
fiction and that's the distinction
between the two four clear often you
know hundreds about ghosts or Spirits or
or some Supernatural things but in the
eyes of the people you know during those
times this is reality this is real
ghosts are real and you know this is not
disputed as you know any any fantasy and
this is what we want to reflect so when
you're walking in the forest during
night you will find these things you
will find ghosts you will find the
spirits of you know of the past and the
deeper you go the more mysterious and
strange it becomes
thank you
if I've caused any existential anxiety
with my presence it might help to try
reframing those stresses in a positive
light
think of me perhaps as a blue shell from
your favorite cart racer I might be
wielded to ruthlessly destroy
hard-earned positions but we can still
have fun maybe there's a lizard driving
a little car isn't that nice
let's celebrate the Same Spirit of cart
racing treachery as our next preview
brings Mario Kart Mayhem to PC here's
Stampede racing Royale
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
2 the search for Life the art team is
looking to balance style and
authenticity to Faithfully represent all
the incredible vehicles used in space
exploration players will see familiar
rocket launches and a host of historical
missions past present and future the
design team have consulted with many
make sure that the gameplay reflects how
it feels to be on the front line of
exciting interplanetary discoveries go
to marserizing2.com to sign up to our
mailing list to be the first to play the
game we have an alpha on the horizon
Frankie I cannot tell you how excited I
am to see Path of Exile 2 in action you
know being something of a Path of Exile
veteran myself sure
what you're about the vexile play time
Falls well below the community average
but the time isn't what matters in that
game I'm also analyzing your chosen
character builds in recent leagues and
no no my build wasn't producing some
traveling DPS simulation fascinating
fascinating Frankie but let's not keep
the good people waiting let's roll the
tape for Path of Exile 2 please
now creatures
your mind
vile abomination
the stench it's getting worse
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
hey everyone my name is Leo and I'm the
lead developer of a new action adventure
game ferocious
I began working on ferocious a few years
ago with the idea of creating a first
person shooter in Timeless Lost World
type of setting combining all the top
actions with exploration and the sense
of wonder
we've always inspired by mysterious
places Frozen time that you may have
seen in movies like King Kong and
Jurassic Park the aim to marry the
setting as you need gameplay
opportunities with classic first versus
shooter mechanics similar to early
installments of franchise like Park rank
Rises
the flexibility of a Unity engine allows
us to get unique solutions to
self-environmental features such as
custom water effects and realistic
vegetation
use a mix of photo scan that handcrafted
assets to create the world both scary
and beautiful
however there are some things waiting
for you majanga that we couldn't find
any reward references for
Soviet improvise
I hope you guys are excited as I am feel
free to wishlist and follow the game on
Steam as we can't wait to share more
about Frozen in the coming months thank
you
welcome to Islands of insight
an epic shared World puzzle Adventure
game set in a world of fantasy Ancient
Wonders and natural beauty
brimming with mysterious puzzles secrets
and Sublime Landscapes for you and other
players to discover
loan altogether
all at your own pace
[Music]
as a Seeker you'll set off on a journey
of knowledge
explore every corner of this Rich
landscape and solve every puzzle you
find
Savor the achievement of every solution
as the world around you unlocks
revealing new challenges to face new
areas to explore and fantastic rewards
to collect
in islands of insight a beautiful realm
of tranquility and Adventure awaits you
embark on the path of Discovery and let
your curiosity guide you through a world
of Oneness
where the answer is always insane
please
[Music]
I might only have an old-fashioned
analog neural network but I'm gonna risk
some data analysis of my own
those Dark Souls games seem like a big
deal huh luckily well from software is
taking a recess to work on giant robots
hexworks is stepping in with a fresh
supply of very depressed nights with
very big swords coming this October
here's your latest look at Lords of the
Fallen
in Lords of the Fallen you'll explore
two parallel Worlds the land of the
living where demonic Knights and hulking
monsters are trying to murder you
and the Spooky umbral plane where the
ghosts of those creatures are trying to
Super murder
using the latest unreal 5 technology
developer hex Works has layered these
realities directly on top of each other
allowing you to portal to the umbrella
plane at will
just try not to die in there
in the spirit of the Dark Souls games
failure will be punished
venturing in dungeons any idiot could do
that but managing an evil dungeon now
we're talking Elite the dungeon of Nile
Book is feared throughout the lands of
fang it is an avant-garde evil structure
combining tradition and disruptive
innovation and it's looking for its new
steward of course we have the most
trained and prepared guards the most
efficient staff the most devious
monsters and the most attractive
Treasures
we're on camera
but wait there's more we have
state-of-the-art production facilities
an r d Center b2c process and an
efficient waste recycling system
our underlings that I mean employees can
fully Express themselves thanks to our
committed HR management and peaceful
social dialogue and can enjoy the use of
Clean safe premises hey don't film that
or you'll be the one cutting the shreds
on the editing floor as a steward your
main task will be to make the dungeon
functional and attractive to adventurers
so they'll want to come here to get
slaughtered and humiliated to achieve
that you'll have access to guards traps
and hexes you'll also get to organize
raids on nearby areas to provide me with
treasures and Relics thanks to your
boundless devotion I zangdar will become
the greatest warlock of the lands of
fang
hahaha
looking for a job that gives meaning to
your life makes the world a better place
than buzz off but if you're organized
servile sneaky and enjoy a positive work
atmosphere come take your chance I'll be
waiting for you in my office
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
are you all right Sean our program
included a gunfight slash dance sequence
to promote Mariachi Legends but your
heavy breathing is indicative of
exhausting Panic or that you are
currently entering childbirth no no
don't worry about anything systems are a
go our schedule is just packed with so
many games I understand Sean I'll
provide assistance
notification day 9 has been updated to
day 10.
what you just can't replace me like roll
roll the system update back I don't want
whatever this is I'm sorry Sean but
support has been discontinued for older
versions what what's up day 9 I'm day
10. the latest software version of
popular gaming host day nine oh the
consequences of my actions hello I am
Frank AI what's up Frank AI I'm day 10.
so the latest software version I suspect
they're going to be at this for a while
so let's just go ahead and fire up a
trailer for a strategy game age of
Sigmar Realms of Ruin while I uh do some
strategizing of my own Dakota start
unplugging things I'll just tell you
when to stop just
hello I am Frank
Commander there is a stench of death
about this place not just from the oryx
death comes for everyone
eventually
except us
[Music]
fortify our position we must claim this
one
Sigma give me spring
[Music]
fakers die for a five points
protect the best game we we need to lose
God
I will take the fight to the Oracle you
hold here
the fight conspires against us but Our
Fate do you
do
foreign
[Music]
sleeper
no no no get toast they haven't finished
it oh sleeper's finished aren't you
we had a dinner sleeper and yet here you
are risking it all to try and break our
contract to end your dependence just
wanted to use them you piece of [__]
nothing wrong with being a tool in a
time of Crisis there's a war on and
while it rages well
there's opportunity
I thought you were an opportunity
sleeper desperate on the run a hard
worker with certain needs
I met your needs I gave you a crew lent
you a ship even hooked you up with a
contract or two and yes I took my share
but that only seems fair
[Music]
I invested in you but then you went and
did this
and now you don't need this
and I don't need you anymore either
paper go now to the ship
this
[Music]
this is just the beginning sleeper
I have found no official case of death
by fomo anywhere on the internet however
I would not suggest risking being the
first case failure to watch the next
section of this show would result in you
missing amazing new content from dread
Pilots miasma Chronicles Pathfinder
Gallows by survivors and parcel core but
first hit critico
thank you
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
if there was an award for being
unbearably cute while also being
unbearably fun there is no question it
would be down to the wire between
Critter Cove and yours truly I mean it's
a strong match-up but please clear
winner after
3411 simulated contests I predict
critico's probability of victory at over
what now is when you start fact checking
now
well while AI might not have mastered
the subtle art of ego boosting it's
already powering new ways to play by
teaming up human storytelling with AI
assistants the team over at Hidden Door
have developed a generative spin on pen
and paper role play it is so
tantalizingly delicious I had no choice
but to send are these adorable
All-Seeing Eye to check in on the
project
[Music]
thank you
hidden door is a role-playing game where
you and your friends come together you
can play in any world you choose you
create your characters and then together
you decide what kind of story you're
gonna have so the idea would be you've
just read a book you can't get it out of
your head now you can go and play your
own story Adventure in the world of that
book that you're directing within the
rules and the Canon that the author has
set and confirmed with a generative AI
narrator
the way it works is that you come in you
choose the world you want to play in
right now we have the Wizard of Oz many
more exciting worlds to come you create
your character you decide the kind of
Adventure you're gonna have by playing
out of your deck of story cards and then
the system creates a unique story
adventure for you and then you can do
anything you want it takes a lot of the
joys of playing a tabletop role-playing
game and brings them into a digital
format and as you play you see a graphic
novel come together dynamically based on
what you choose to do and how the world
and the story reacts to you it's like an
improv show where even though you might
play the same cards you get a different
unique story every time so you throw
words in it comes up with uh suggested
things you might do you pick something
and then it reacts to you and then along
with our AI narrator who plays the role
of say the game master you can go on any
Adventure you want and you can do
anything and the system and the story
will continue based on your choices
[Music]
we are working with authors and folks
who make some really exciting TV shows
and other media to bring those worlds
into the platform and the system
supports anything fictional so it does
do science fiction it does do fantasy it
does you know period romance
um which you can think of as more
relationship based gameplay in addition
to sort of your standard action-based
gameplay or sort of Dungeon Crawl based
storytelling
while there may be a million Star Wars
games in the world if you were playing
one on hidden door because of our AI
narrator and the story engine the
choices you make matter so when you
decide that you want to become say the
governor of tatiween you can do that and
the world changes around you and your
character you are able to meaningfully
alter the plot of the entire world in a
way that was never pre-written or
pre-scripted there's no limit to the
number of characters you might encounter
the locations or the stories you can
tell in Hidden Door
or anywhere you can access the web so
you can play on desktop you can play on
your mobile device you can play on a
tablet
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
it looks like hidden door is cooking up
one hell of a winning combination am I
right Frank AI it's a Nissan showing
speaking of winning you two can achieve
Victory with the PT gaming Show battle
pass and free bonuses as you level up
your viewer rank or upgrade to a gold
tip pass for only 9.99 what are you
doing I'm incorporating lucrative life
service techniques to maximize the
show's profitability how would a battle
pass for a stream even work with the go
to class viewers can end exclusive
rewards like viewing the show's trailers
1.5 seconds early and boosters for view
around experience look I admire the
initiative but I think for now let's
just go ahead and table streams of
service sadly major production decisions
are only accessible for those reached
Bureau rank 80. you can however unlock
immediate access with 1 800 Shore points
purchasable for 9.99 you made show
production of battle pass reward
is anyone close to unlocking that okay
let's go 69 blaze it has just achieved
Euro rank 58. oh god oh okay uh uh
Dakota find my wallet and for now uh
let's check out a new Dungeon Crawler
from the Don't Starve devs at clay
entertainment here's your first look at
dread Pilots
[Music]
all right
what's up
[Music]
something
fun
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]
you've harnessed your glove's power and
now you want to find me
you don't know what's making the miasma
angry and it's spreading across America
twisting this once great nation into a
lethal Wasteland
[Music]
in the future
go break through the wall and find me
and if you do
maybe I will tell you my secret
but Revelations must be earned
don't starve yourself with excitement
for dread Pilots or you might leave a
miasma worthy of a Chronicle
hey hey that's pretty good that's good
stuff thank you text generation coming
up secret facilities bio weapons
development
zombie experimentation It's all under
the corporate umbrella in this
management Sim and you are the evil CEO
I mean I can't blame you for
diversifying that's just good business
sense let's take a look at Undead ink
[Music]
and now it's with great pleasure I
introduce one of endswell Medical's
biggest success stories director colon
thank you and welcome to all of you who
are starting your own franchises
today I'm here to talk about building a
thriving business
my apologies there has been a
development that requires my immediate
attention
[Music]
sir we're hearing whatever your concerns
may be
[Music]
structural integrity and power all
hanging in there sir extent of the
outbreak unknown next move director tell
your men ETA five minutes
um
[Music]
wait don't shoot yeah director Coleman
hey man sir are you okay I got a little
bitten but I hang it in there director
I'm all good they have a cure upstairs
head back up there is a shot with your
name on it thanks man I'm not as worried
for a second
I'm trying to love a business here
Janine get the marketing team and those
rookies back on the line in 10. oh and
then espresso yes sir thank you and
Janine can I get something from my head
of course director
name brand only not our stuff
quality control issues downstairs
[Music]
foreign
thank you
okay hey look I've been looking through
Frank ai's data log and I found a file
named confidential game trailer 44.
codename Omicron Delta November
underscore final currency final and
parenthesis 2.0 underscore revised.mp4
Horton not to lose the trust of your AI
assistant
so let's just watch it really quick
[Music]
This Must Be Love
D him
no because I want to understand it
someday
or at least find as many answers as
possible
[Music]
astrogator we shouldn't behave here as
if we were at home
species
[Music]
so there was life here before
everything that happened here overwhelms
me
okay
what is there to understand
have to destroy it
even if it means destroying everything
[Music]
coming up we'll see a Theme Park Builder
that's only days away releasing on PC
later this week Park Beyond is a
spiritual successor to Classics like
Roller Coaster Tycoon Roller Coaster
Tycoon 2 roller coaster magnate 9 roller
coaster Auto 27 and roller coaster God
Emperor forty thousand okay okay let's
not go off the rails look as fun as the
carnival is we all know the games aren't
the most balanced because basically
Carneys are op luckily for you our
prizes are so much easier to win let's
take a look at Park Beyond
you perceive The Invisible Thread that
connects us to each other
the emotions that unite us without us
even realizing it
the desire to move forward to surpass
our limitations
take on challenges greater than
ourselves
all these feelings make us visioneers
visioneers are architects who are
dedicated to making their childhood
dreams a reality
empowered to achieve the impossible
architects who want to offer the world
their most beautiful memories
[Music]
free Spirits in search of Adventure and
new challenges
indelible moments of amazement and
laughter those we love
become a visionaire
go beyond the fun
[Music]
as an AI I have no need for material
possessions but good news PC gaming show
viewers can take advantage of the
following promotional contest by
following the instructions on the screen
if this product and or service
stimulates your orbital cortex follow
the instructions on the screen
[Music]
thank you
evil stirs in the depths of Gallo smile
three Heroes stepped forth to contain
the darkness Within
a legendary fighter a Peerless strength
and skill a cunning Rogue full of deadly
surprises
and a powerful wizard wielding the fury
of the elements together
they are destined to confront the hordes
of Undead and their deadly Masters
again and again
attaining new heights of power
and skill
but what hope of day to seal away the
whispering time
surely there can be no hope
of surviving
Gallows spire
[Music]
thank you
introducing diesel Legacy
join the open Beta now on Steam
[Music]
two versus two action
but not out
local and online multiplayer
real match worldwide rollback neck way
[Music]
determine the faith of the Iron City
foreign
[Music]
it's time we honor an overlooked hero
the noble delivery cyclist powering the
gig economy with their aching calves now
you might ask
Don are you just feeling a little guilty
because you gave your credit card
details to the AI assistant now someone
has to deliver the 57 Parcels you
ordered before you noticed in short yes
but if this next exclusive is anything
to go by we'll all be saluting the
delivery workers of this fine Nation
gosh dang it let's take a look at parcel
core
all right
[Music]
hello inquisitive fear my name is Will
Will Barr and that was an example of a
micro taser you say when you're Shilling
on behalf of an obscure video game
developer like very good entertainment
you have a finite amount of time to
explain why Discerning intellectual
players such as yourself
it should be excited about being thrust
into the exciting hyotian world of
parcel core that's right to skip the
modernity of daily life and slip into
the spandex of one of our many colorful
bicycle Messengers embrace the gig
economy and forget the security stable
salary and basic workplace rights less
cool jobs offer as you race Through Time
weaving through alleys to find gravity
as you ride up walls leap from rooftops
startle pigeons
well it's kind of like a career in video
game development except without all the
cool traversal stuff so yeah really just
the exploitation
but I'd digress sign a casual work
agreement with one of three rival
Courier corporations all vying to become
the most profitable business in town but
be warned a maniacal scheme is a foot
that threatens more than just the
business model our protagonists operate
under
so it's up to you
School Courier
on grilled chicken cheese and try to
melts and
save the world
[Music]
hi everyone I'm Max from greater games a
two-man Studio based in Sweden working
on the game table though currently
available in Early Access
[Music]
hmm
welcome to fabledum
sorry about the pigs
hello micro friends
we have a new Mission Soldier
[Music]
looking crazy
oh don't mind Sean he's just entering
our PC game pass giveaway we've got a
bunch of one month subscriptions for new
members to try the service to get a
chance at procuring one visit the URL on
screen now
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
sure before we continue with more
exciting previews I've generated a
simple tactic to improve the show's
Revenue stream yeah great tell me more I
have allow viewers to pay a small fee
for a bespoke on-screen shout out got
good228 right great to be watching PC
gaming show once again excellent work
Sean anko hey I'm touched and a little
wealthier keep them coming see Blaze
paladins right did Sean actually fire
his team dick move bro look look you
have to understand that this show needs
to focus on long-term sustainability
fired by Sean 23 writes I have sworn the
blood out my Vengeance will not be
denied okay it looks like that's it our
shout outs feature is broken I'm so
sorry that's going to be all for sure I
haven't looked any errors Sean well I'm
seeing red flags across the board and
it's a real tragedy just can't be helped
just like I can't help wanting to see
more previews and with that here's
creepy Jar's new Sci-Fi Survival game
era
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
[Laughter]
foreign
[Music]
will magic restores our crew from before
yes before
black person are just let us finish the
quest now
treasure we will find with our powers
combined a word we will show to our
captain
below
the Inquisition blocks our way they see
us as prey
ignatia is their leader you're the world
to exceed her
treasure she pursues across the ocean
blue she'll conquered a brine for her
grand designs
Mario
[Music]
foreign
EXO Rally Championship might be racing
its way across the stars but it's
already raced its way into my heart
anyways if you're not aware I've got
something of a history with a real-time
strategy genre and funnily enough at
Labs like deepmind those same RTS games
just so happen to be a valuable testing
ground for World leading AI research hmm
curious can it be just a coincidence
then that I'd end up the kind of man to
name himself in AI visionary
I mean probably but what's no
coincidence is my excitement for the
eagerly anticipated RTS from former
Warcraft and Starcraft devs at Frost
giant Studios it's stormgate and today
we don't just get the chance to get some
exclusive first look at some stormgate
gameplay but we're also joined by Frost
Giants president and game director Tim
Campbell here to tell us exactly how
stormgate will Delight all mines
artificial or otherwise thanks so much
for joining us fam thanks it's great to
be here now I've been following
stormgate for years but for those of us
who haven't what is stormgate stormgate
is our modern take on the classic
railtime strategy game formula it's what
we think of as a spiritual successor to
franchises like Warcraft Starcraft
Command and Conquer and real-time
strategy games are are the type of game
where you can control an entire
Battlefield so this classic RTS formula
includes harvesting resources building
sprawling bases commanding huge armies
on the battlefield what is it about
stormgate that's new we believe that the
RTS genre is something that should be
enjoyed by players of all skills levels
and so we put a lot of effort into
making sure that stormgate feels good
whether you're a pro with high technical
skill and you love competitive play or
whether it's something that you just
want to be able to relax with and
experience a story now Tim
I understand that you brought for all of
us but in particular for me a present to
show today what are you going to show
Tim we are going to show gameplay from
the pre-alpha of stormgate yeah now this
is something that we are big Believers
in at Frost giant we want to share this
current state of the game today
a look
this looks like an RTS tell me what
we're seeing this is the classic start
to a 1v1 match what you're seeing here
is the human faction as they're sending
workers out to harvest resources they're
starting to construct building they
actually build them by 3D printing them
from the ground up and you can see them
now starting to train troops so they can
have an army that goes out in the field
to fight yeah and I mean right here we
see in the corner coming up this is this
looks like a scout unit yeah that is
literally a cybernetic dog with laser
eyes it is called the Scout okay it's
designed for early game it's a unique
unit to the human faction right and you
can see them now running through the
base trying to see what information he
can find out about his enemy yeah I mean
scouting and information is such an
important part of our TS games it really
is and this is something that we've
embraced early game the Scout Yoon has
been designed so it can actually sense
units Beyond its sight radius so it's a
it's especially useful early on
so we're heading into what looks like
the first engagement of this game what
are we seeing well what we're seeing
right here is the red Scout getting
surprised by a group of blue troops
coming through the light Force which is
the new train type and the Twist on on
the Tactical Battlefield here and how do
these light forests work the light
Forest lets smaller units move through
them they have concealments it's allowed
blue to raid Red's base in which case
red is barely getting a turret built
with their speed building from their
workers it's another human faction
advantage and they're about to pop out a
couple extra Defenders here from their
Mech base so we got these huge mechs and
I mean just visually it looks like they
are countering the heck out of these
blue infantry but can these rednecks fit
through the forest no they're too big to
go through they're heavy units they're
designed to use their chain guns to go
through groups of enemies but they can't
fit through the light Force which blew
new and used to his advantage
okay so we're in mid game this is
normally where you make some big Tech
decisions what's red up to you're seeing
red commit to a tech path that gives
them big Battlefield mechs and air units
like this Evac and it looks like they're
just dropping right on top of blue who
was
killing a chicken what's the chicken
there yeah that's a giant chicken with a
Viking helmet on it uh use your
imagination stormgates and pre-alpha and
that's art that we haven't gotten to yet
but imagine it as a big Mad Max Raider
ice the most threatening placeholder art
for now and oh I see red diving onto
blue and hey picking back up into the
air transport that's some classic high
level micro it is and it's really
important for stormgate that we maintain
a high skill ceiling so the players can
express themselves on the battlefield by
maneuvering and how they interact with
the battlefield and here we have the
final fight of the game and it looks
like blue is coming up against those Max
red is trapped on the other side of the
trees oh wait they can blast through
them now and blues dodging these
enormous shots and we can also see blue
swarming in from both sides this is not
looking good for red no it's pretty Grim
right red is on the ropes right here and
they've been outmaneuvered they're
caught in the corner here between two
different forces coming in with a mobile
pincer man and of course there's the ggs
the most classic ending to an RTS game
Gigi get tastosis on that stat outside
of 1v1 what's coming up for stormgate
what you've seen today is just the tip
of the iceberg we have so much more in
store we're going to be revealing a
bunch of stuff about stormgate the rest
of this year we're introducing new modes
we have a three player versus AI
Cooperative mode we have team-based
competitive modes we're gonna be sharing
information about our storyline and
campaign we have new factions beyond the
humans that you just saw today but Tim
what if I want to play the game right
now if you want to play the game as soon
as possible you wish list stormgate on
Steam and you go to playstoremgate.com
to sign up for the beta we're starting
closed testing in July once again go to
steam and wishlist stormgate Tim thank
you so much again for joining us not
just to talk about the 1v1 footage you
shared but the future content plans of
stormgate it makes the RTS players
dreams come true
which might not be your dreams I mean
your dreams might be filled with
gloriously grimy Deus ex-inspired sci-fi
fisticuffs with a fiendishly Star Wars
vibe to it if so get a load of this
latest trailer for Fortune's run
[Music]
[Applause]
here
[Music]
is
the Sun
sun it's been in the room too many poor
girls
[Music]
thank you
whatever
[Music]
Ben you were about to Embark upon the
great Crusade towards which we have
striven these many months the eyes of
the world are upon you the hopes and
prayers of Liberty loving people
everywhere march with you
full confidence in your courage Devotion
to duty and skill in battle
will accept nothing less than full
Victory good luck and let us all beseech
the blessing of almighty God upon this
great and Noble undertaking
foreign
[Music]
thank you
I'm so sorry
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
oh it's Matt Jack wishlist now
thank you
[Music]
as an AI I have no need for material
possessions but good news PC gaming show
viewers can take advantage of the
following promotional contest by
following the instructions on the screen
if this product and or service
stimulates your orbital cortex follow
the instructions on the screen
Frank we've seen impressive almost like
unrealistic Tech on display today it's
just a shame our viewers at home can't
get their hands on some of that bleeding
edge Hardware your concerns are both
unnecessary and convenient Sean as the
long-term Vanguard of gaming anywhere
continues to offer high-end PC Hardware
considering their extraterrestrial
Origins it comes as no surprise look I
don't know how to tell you this Frankie
but they're not actually made by aliens
websites in my trading model contain
compelling evidence to the contrary Sean
the truth is out there
great but let's do some truth telling of
our own and hear what Alienware is
offering to Folks at home
Alienware has been a part of my
professional life for a while now from
the games you play to what you do for
work that's very Hardware intensive when
using Alienware you get a performance
that is very very difficult to match it
doesn't have just the kind of like
generic Gamer look to it literally
everything I do is powered by Alienware
and it just makes me so happy
thank you
don't miss your shot at Alienware
giveaway goodness scan that code now I
mean Frankie can you believe this we got
an Alienware M18 laptop with an Intel
Core I9 processor for the fine price
point of free oh it's enough to get
anyone's blood pumping as you know Sean
I'm a network of predictive algorithms
and generative software I am
fundamentally incapable of belief look I
I understand I also don't have blood
would you like me to kill blood Sean God
no absolutely not anything but that
let's move on to literally anything else
so what's next uh
well this is a little awkward let's have
a look at some incoming DLC for vampire
survivors
who boy
what if we gave it
[Applause]
[Music]
finger
foreign
[Music]
we are only a couple months out from the
full release of Baldur's Gate 3. I
literally cannot tell you how excited I
am to try out some of the character
builds I've got going on up here I'm
thinking of running Leica Mage tank kind
of vibe and wait Frank
can you generate like an awesome
character art for me in like a DND style
like look I want to be a wizard but
fully Gandalf out with like a staff and
like blasting spells like that can you
like give me a sample piece of art
Wellness here you are Sean
oh dear God this was generated in
seconds while a professional artist
would take hours if not days yes that's
that is true it's hard to tell this
wasn't the work of a trained
professional but do you have any
professional artist work you know just
to like compare I do thanks to the
YouTube animators extraordinaire at
mashed here's an original animation for
larion's Border skate 3.
my fellow adventurers the road to
Boulder's Gate has been long we have
fought cultists of a strange new God
back
fearsome Knowles and gone Toe to Toe
with creatures from Beyond this plane
today we faced our greatest foe yet he
was just so strong and I think his blood
was acid I'm not sure how that even
works like anatomically tomorrow we find
Higher Ground then rain down upon him
with 100 hours no first I will
incapacitate him with a fit of hideous
laughter then we will fill his bog with
grease and set it on fire and if he
attempts to escape the blaze fear not
for I will keep my eye out please don't
even lazelle's puns are more amusing
among youth Yankee I am considered
extremely humorous enough we must defeat
this foe somewhere Within These Twisted
swamps dwells a hag who possesses a
potent potion an Elixir that could grant
us the ability to converse with the
creature however attaining it will
necessity potato trade give me his
spleen
steal your nerves friends I will now
attempt to reason with the creature
most Mighty Beast though you defeated us
once we have returned to seek your
guidance impart your knowledge upon us
and teach us the source of your power
oh I didn't know you speak frog gosh I'm
so sorry about yesterday I'm so
embarrassed you know ever since the
heart turned me into a frog I'd been
down in the dark
laughs
[Music]
cities are incredibly hard to make in
RPGs because you have to make sure that
every single nuke and cranny has
something to do you have to make sure
that it's different so you have to be
incredibly creative given that the name
of the game is bulbous gate the city was
really going to be the thing that people
were going to be talking about the city
of balder's gate is seamless which it
originally wasn't you only can judge the
game when you have all the components
together and if the mix doesn't work we
start over at some point he said like
can't we just connect everything and
that was uh that was a very interesting
day one of the things that that's done
is it's brought a level of believability
and immersion and also complexity that
wouldn't have been there otherwise now
was this seamless giant organism and it
really really felt good it's been able
to look out of the window and see down
the city slopes so you're seeing down to
all the docks and you're like one of my
teammates might be down there they might
be running around down there we worked
on it as a painting almost you start
with a sketch it's a very basic line and
then you just start adding layers and
layers
we can put lots more of the city onto
the screen than they could in 1998. so
we can do something that is more
immersive richer has more texture to it
it feels like you are walking around a
place where there are lots and lots of
people living their actual lives you
have crowds that are walking around can
talk to pretty much anybody and they
react to every single thing it's very
alive in that sense every person that
you meet in valder's gate has got a
story to them
all the things that you can
do Heather
we actually build anticipation through
all these characters that you've met
through all these situations that you've
been through all the stories that you
have been following and all the
decisions that you've been making they
all come to fruition in that lower City
and the great thing is if you so choose
you can be another bad thing that's
happening to the city you can arrive and
be like this place is on fire and then
you can throw petrol all over it
during production we felt like the city
was our was our destination we spent I
think three times four times as much
effort on the city than we originally
planned but the results the result the
the feeling of walking in there is just
fantastic
you have this constant jostling or
things that are very much of the real
world and then you can indulge in a
completely Fantastical and then when you
walk into the city the noise of
everybody talking to each other the
knowledge that everywhere you look you
can go there and you can do something
the knowledge that you can fly through
it it's great so the thing that I was
the most afraid of when we started
making this game turned out to be the
thing that I'm the most proud of
[Music]
thank you
larion Studios breaks the classic RPG
series out of a two decade retirement
when Baldur's Gate 3 finally releases on
August 31st up next we're forging ahead
with more fantasy as flame-headed
Fighters face ferocious foes in
a roguelike after all what's a roguelike
without an onslaught of algorithmic
Terrors
I feel like there's a lot of that going
on around here lately
anyways here's the latest trailer for
Ember nights
thank you
[Music]
we can be heroes
foreign
[Music]
what what
let's go
[Music]
would you like the endless loot of
Terror death repeat in the upcoming self
extraction horror Macabre in Macabre you
and your friends will team up to
confront interdimensional Terrors
venturing deep into unstable time risk
tasks with uncovering the source of
terrifying anomalies a great way to
enjoy the outdoors
built in unreal5 this exclusive debut
will be out later this year in Early
Access
[Music]
you seriously don't have any signal not
even one bar there's nothing
to mention there's like a super weird
scary thing getting around inside the
ring now was that a bear have you ever
had a bear sound like that before you've
seen Affair before you guys look lost
come on you freeze to death out here I
suppose you're looking for the lodge
here take this I call it the atomic
space shifter yeah if anything goes
wrong not that it will I can pull you
back out a lot of folks have come up
here looking for answers it's weird it's
like time runs differently here
we gotta find the others dude
[Music]
haha I can't believe it worked this is
it this is the cater
ah you're alive
ready to go back in
[Music]
we thought we had billions of years
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
goodbye
to John prepared
soft Landings captain
foreign
as great as earthless looks it makes you
wonder how are we in the real world
going to fare when our big beautiful sun
enters its Twilight years me I'm
optimistic who knows what we'll achieve
by then every billionaire funded space
rocket that detonates moments after
takeoff is one more step on the winding
road of progress
up next tie on those togas and make
Merry with fine wine as all roads lead
to this newest City Builder here's her
first look at Nova Roma
[Music]
foreign
War is Over
all we want is to return home
to the newborn Czechoslovakia we fought
for
brothers
and sisters
thank you
none of us thought this part of the
journey would be the most difficult we
still hope to see our home once again
across the endless snow fields of
Siberia
through territory disputed by the red
and white armies
by armored train in a harsh winter
far from our loved ones
outnumbered by enemies we fight to make
our way
surrounded by Wilderness we manage in
order to survive this
is our last chance
[Music]
our last train home
[Applause]
[Music]
will you lead us
pairing Squad tactics with historic
inspiration last train home is based on
real events in the aftermath of World
War One however historians continue to
uncover records describing train
passengers traveling homewards some
dating as recently as 2023
whether any train home is truly the last
Remains the subject of academic debate
history is clear on one thing though
puppets can't be trusted as proof watch
as Sesame Street meets survival Horror
in my friendly neighborhood
the antenna activated itself last night
started broadcasting that old puppet
show over the news you need to turn that
thing off
all right
the last job of the day is always the
worst
hey stay back
[Music]
wow
let's do this
[Music]
you and me
yeah
oh I think I ended early can we uh go
back to the beginning
a Sprint Victory and points out for
grabs right here
and they push more I wonder they can't
afford to sit back and relax now
oh and that's a crash
now
and McLaren with a great overtake
stay right here because we're just
getting started
hey Frank AI how are the metrics looking
are we like doing numbers we're
attracting considerable viewership Sean
however I've identified a simple
programming adjustment to Target
underrepresented segments of our
audience demographic shall I execute it
well hell yeah let's do it
ah cornering the V tuber Market smart
very smart I'm just not really sure this
is my vibe but since we're on time
crunch let's see what's next for
subnautica likes in space with a trailer
for breath Edge 2.
[Music]
thank you
oh
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
man there are so many great video games
in this year's show Frank AI what do we
know about sand sand is a fine granular
substance composed of mineral particles
it is finer than gravel but Corsa than
silt yes but it's also a brand new
Survival game set in an alternate
history where austro-hungarian soldiers
smuggle space Salvage across alien
deserts I don't understand that sentence
would you like to hear more about sound
types oh no need I'm about to know
plenty let's take a look at Sam
[Music]
thank you
foreign
restaurants
[Music]
we have reached the end of this year's
show and we're saving something very
exciting for the end
Dune Awakening the survival MMO
adaptation of the classic sci-fi series
Frank AI what have you got for us for
the big finale if you like I can fill
the room with sand
that's a little literal don't you think
but what if we had like
costumes oh dude's got some really cool
costumes we have the steel suits the
Royal garments oh my God I could dress
up maybe as like a giant sand worm it
will require 3 million teraflops of
processing power to render you as a
sunburn
I mean
don't worry about it we can we can skip
the costuming it's just something that
like Frankie and I used to do like not
you like the real Frankie with the fun
hair who's not a computer
ah man there was this one year where she
was a shark and then oh oh and she was
like a Mech pilot and oh I had a
spaceship and there was this other time
with togas and I had this really nice
robe
anyways just forget it I'm living in the
past I shouldn't even miss this stuff I
mean we're adults right
[Music]
do you still want to do the costumes
make sure I want to do the gentress a
bit so bad I'm sorry I tried to fire
everyone and make money with computers
shut up and put the costume on
Frankie would you do the honors gladly
here is an exclusive interview with the
team making a survival MMO that's more
Source after than a suitcase stuffed
with spice melange it's June Awakening
[Music]
my name is Joe bilos I'm the creative
director on June Awakening so June
Awakening is a survival open world
massively multiplayer game it is a game
where players are invited to explore the
world of June they involve themselves in
politics they involve themselves in
entry they involve themselves in combat
they have to survive on the most
dangerous planet in the universe
and through this experience they come to
know the factions in the world and the
universe
so when June Awakening begins you are a
Castaway on the planet in the Deep
desert and all you have is a knife that
you've made out of scrap metal and you
need to creep into enemy camps and knife
them in the back and steal the water
from their steel suits by the end of the
game perhaps you're running a guild you
have a fleet of vehicles ornithopters
flying in formation sand bikes cruising
across the desert beneath them tanks
kicking up a cloud of dust as you drive
to a spice blue in the distance in order
to harvest with your guild and you see
in the distance another guild coming
towards you and just as you Clash you
hear the rumble of a sand worm coming
that's combat in June Awakening
my name is William somerbach I'm the
game director on Dune Awakening
you start out in the desert surviving
clinging to life and in the end you
might become someone like the
bernharkonen and then you try to cling
to power arakis is the most dangerous
planet in the universe surviving on the
rakes means that you need to prepare for
sandstorms you need to find water it's a
constant threat against survival the
sand worm every time you try to cross
the desert that sandworm will come you
will sometimes outrun it sometimes you
may not
[Music]
June Awakening is built upon a
foundation of Five Pillars survival
which is obviously everything you'd
expect to see in a survival game it's
water discipline it's the surviving the
sandstorms that sweep across Iraqis
then we have politics and Intrigue which
speaks to the faction gameplay of the
game it's about you know siding with one
of the factions thinking about how they
work together perhaps assassinating
members of the other factions
then there's infinite exploration
infinite exploration which is one of the
things I'm most excited about is how the
world changes over time we have a
concept called the coriola storm and
when it sweeps across the landscape the
Sands shift revealing new points of
interest hiding others making the game
renewed every week
then we have combined arms combined arms
is our combination of vehicles melee
combat range combat and abilities all
working together to create a seamless
sandbox combat experience and finally we
have expression and customization which
is really more than just talking about
like the visual expression and
customization which of course we have
armor sets and clothing and a robust
character creation but in addition to
that it's really about play the way you
want to play do you want to be a Trader
you can do that do you want to be a
fighter of course you can do that do you
want to be a spy maybe that's the
gameplay you're looking for all of these
things built into these pillars
so the Journey of the player we've
divided that into four parts we think of
them as survive protect expand control
the survive part means that you're up
against the planet itself and you're
Clinging On To Life
in the protect phase you've gathered
some stuff you might have a base but you
also want to make sure that nobody else
comes to to take it away from you so you
try to build defenses and make sure that
your base is in the clear
then in the expand phase you lift your
gaze and you look around and you see
that others have stuff as well and you
might want to take their stuff then in
the control phase you may find yourself
being a part of a guild or even the
leader of a guild then the goal is to
control the flow of spice on Iraqis
however you're never safe there's always
someone looking around the corner can
you really trust your second in command
so the goal of the control phase is that
you are clinging to control whenever you
get into combat in the desert of Iraqis
try to get it over with quickly because
not only are you fighting human
combatants but the planet Iraqis itself
is the greatest protagonist there is
and with that's the PC gaming show 2023
is done and what a show it was and uh
what a lesson for me honestly AI excels
at plenty but only an absolute doofus
would think it can replace the human
touch I mean you'd have to be an
irredeemable Bozo like a real human
dumpster to pull that so uh that's the
end of Frank AI you are getting the band
back together I mean yeah if we get
another show next year then yeah you
betcha if
well you know Dakota you guys pretty
smart I mean I think he's actually the
CEO now of PC Gamer and awesome City
area Publications and IPS I think he's
got some really great ideas but he also
categies for some very influential
people on the golf course life comes at
your fast I guess either way see you
next year bye bye
bye bye
[Music]
thank you
camera speed
hold on my lips are sweating okay here
comes okay here it is everyone quiet on
set here I come this is a big moment
okay
necessary data acquired
we want them to be able to react in the
middle of a battle with maneuvering with
using abilities with targeting things
more carefully and so we've slowed it
down just a little bit to give players
that breathing room to be able to
express their skill
I don't know what to do now
imagine
if I continued reading on that take that
was above average imagine that
that's not all wrong [__] balls here
we go one more time
oh hold on I have a row shoelace no it's
solved I solved the problem Tyler took
care of it by himself Talent as an adult
I'm ready tell me when
if there was an award for being
unbearably cute while also being
unbearably fun there's no question it'd
be down to the wire between Critter Cove
and yours truly
now I've been following stormgate for
years at this point but for those of us
who aren't me tell us what the [__]
mattress looking
we're attracting considerable viewership
keep going Cuban oh
holy [__] [__]
I really apologize
don't get ice cream next years
holy [__]
because I had to keep myself like this
I'm no free burning out of my mouth this
is very difficult sorry
dude I didn't hit you I'm so sorry I
really apologize everyone I I farted and
it it smells like an abandoned pig farm
up here on set it's
uh
yeah oh my God okay all right okay
Frank AI how are the metrics looking
oh
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]